he's Deion Sanders hall-of-famer and a
fell Network analyst always great to see
him you see at the Super Bowl and see
him tonight Friday at 9:00 Eastern NFL
Network's Super Bowl prime also see Dion
on NFL Network's NFL gameday prime
following Super Bowl 52 well this is the
way you say that prime always great to
see I asked this of Michael Irvin Lenny
came in the other day I said how fast
could do around the 40 right now didn't
we do this last year you ran backwards
beat do you beat all of us all of you
you ran backwards I'm for inclusive so
if you had now you had the bad toe
yeah wait you're gonna show us the bad
toe you know we're family
how did you get that bad toes that's
three surgeries mooch tells me that that
towards is flipping everybody off so we
don't mean to be giving you the finger
if you're watching this toe ladies it's
a nice pedicure right but how did you
get that
I don't it's the closest thing they
called to turf toe and it was just
horrendous I mean I've never felt
anything like it
and it was so bad that it was up it
begun to be hammer toe you know so they
had to shave it down and straighten it
out and that's what I got but you could
you could hit it on top with a hammer
because it's numb it's numb right now
but it hurts well that's like mr. deeds
with right took a crowbar and they're
they're hitting his his feet but how
fast if you're healthy one step one step
best in the next man you can't put a
time on prime let me tell you something
I want to thank you all I want to thank
you all you guys helped me have one of
the best fourth of July's ever and I
bought a spot in the country in Canton
Texas which I adore but the grill the
Traeger grill you have no idea it's for
real I mean we fed hundreds thank you I
was a hit I tell people about it because
they say do you really like I said
yes we have meet Friday tomorrow here we
missed out on that we have a Trager girl
we're bringing in but I tell everybody
the same thing it's I've never had a
better girl is of when it showed up I
thought it was a joke like this is from
the damn Freddy come on okay well I'm
gonna open it up and somebody's gonna
jump out I'm curious if you how much
offense did you play how long did you
play offense in the NFL or no in high
school as a starting quarterback okay
and then I called my own place my senior
at the line of scrimmage yes yes how did
you run into line no that was a team guy
Oh see you wanted to prove you could
throw no I read the defense and I call
what was uh what was right could you
have played quarterback in the NFL
no college yeah but not an NFL why
because I don't feel like I was tall
enough or accurate enough and I didn't
want to I didn't have the desire to you
gotta have passion for whatever you do
that went passionate buddy and if I was
passionate about shedding these guys
down that's what I was passionate could
you been like Michael Vick yeah
who's a better athlete athlete yeah okay
something else he changed a game he
changed the game Lamar Jackson is like
that will they give him a chance they
better to change well wouldn't it I
don't know I don't know this shoe I
don't know how I don't know what they
look at now there's old-school
stereotypes obviously here yeah I don't
know what they see when they see old
school makes old fool that's what I was
talking yeah yeah that kid there is the
lecture he's unbelievable if he don't
get a chance a rightful chance in the
NFL there's a problem something's wrong
with our system because now you're
taking other guys that you're trying to
force it's almost like you criticize we
talked about this with the Jean Watson
yesterday you criticize him because he
can run and coming to the NFL then when
he gets to the NFL and he shows you
can elongate a play and make something
happen now you applaud it it doesn't
make sense just give him his love Deion
Sanders joining us here in the man cave
of course NFL Network analyst and
where's your Hall of Fame jacket let me
see I got three of them I got two made
and they gave me one because I didn't
trust them
the fit so I got the fabric and made my
own what's it say on the inside if you
played now how different would you be or
have to be I would be part owner of a
friendship well I'm still playing that's
that much I would command I probably
would have a television show follow me
everywhere while I'm playing it would be
unbelievable I could even met imagine
playing in today's game with social
media in all the the conditions thereof
of it it would be unbelievable what had
been good or bad for you great because
people would have really gotten an
opportunity to know me because I was I
was really guarded when I played I
didn't really want people to know me i I
only wanted you to know Prime I didn't
want you to know dia and that's two
different entities how would you play
Brady I would just deal with the guy in
front of me then Brady would have to
play himself so as long as you take care
of business yeah but did you ever feel
like I've taken away somebody here and
nobody's like it you know it wasn't my
job I know but you're not really in the
flow of everything cuz he stayed away
from I am the flow of everything when
you force it away from when Jalen Ramsey
Patrick Peterson these guys boo yay all
these guys can just do what they do
they've done their jobs no matter if you
stay away from them or not you forced
him into something football is so
simplistic is that when I play receiver
and I'm lining up I can read the
coverage and I know that balls supposed
to come to me that's how simplistic Emma
if I'm on the defensive side of the ball
I know what we've done with the
coverages I know that quarterback
I'm his read you got to throw at me
that's how simplistic idiot so when you
do your job you know you've done your
job
you shut it down could you play the way
you played now I would play better
no but you can't put your hands on
somebody yes you can
oh yes you can they say you can't you
just have to be discreet know the things
that get quarterbacks in trouble you've
got to understand 95% our defensive
backs played not to get beat only 5%
play to make a play always played to
make a play so when the ball is in the
air these guys are beaten in they're
afraid so they get they panic and now
you get past interference you don't see
a lot of pass interference on the great
ones you see some but not the great ones
that's out there today how many sacks
did you have in your career maybe
probably one or two why would you is
this a fair conversation most decorated
athletes the best team athletes if Brady
wins his sixth Michael Jordan or Tom
Brady not most athletic first of all
Jordan is Jordan then there's us don't
don't do that
that's a cuss word that's plenty Jordan
set the standard for all of us on the
field off the field every business
everything he is that leave that alone
there's just like Ali don't mention
oddly names with none of us Ali Jordan
then you get down there to us do you
allow Colin Kaepernick into the
conversation no no it feels like that is
being forced that he's the modern-day or
uh you know ollie
it's being forced out of today's
generation not by old schools not by old
fools not by people that walk that walk
and lived in that generation and really
live in that generation Ali was Ollie
ollie risk so much of not only the sport
but his life for for us did you ever
meet him yes I had two most one of the
most fascinating conversations with mom
this
my guy you had a staff leader black
Superman that was my guy so when I had
an opportunity to meet him I was like a
kid in the candy shop and we just said
there and and conversate is not gonna
understand everything he said and it was
it was it was so much of a blessing to
meet your guy and he is the guy that you
wanted to meet you know what I'm saying
yes sometimes you meet somebody and you
go I wish I had in a minute is a jack in
the jack-in-the-box jumping up to like
dang yeah to let down Ali was Ali and I
know that we're looking at the social
causes with Kaepernick and if that's
gonna prevent some wonderful things we
cannot minimize what his plight and what
he's done and he donated a million
dollars like you said he was going to
donated the final portion of that but
going back to what Ali went through well
I mean he gave up his career he didn't
want to go to the war in his prime
yes in his prime I'm talking about on
the back side of him in his prime
yeah yeah but the way he and I would say
it was Ollie than everybody who came
after him who wanted to try to be Ollie
and be braggadocious and you know be
colorful charismatic imagine Ollie with
social media it wouldn't be fair it
wouldn't be fair it would be
unbelievable yeah yeah Jordan to say
Jordans the same way not to Jordan
articulates himself like Ali did but we
want us we want to know more better
athlete you were Jordan athlete yeah
what is your definition of an athlete I
don't know I think it Apple eat has the
ability to do multiple things okay at a
very high level could Michael have
played baseball getting a profound guy
in this conversation both Vincent
Jackson
if it wasn't for Bo it wouldn't be no
prime so let's start with Bo is Bo the
best athlete I believe so see I would
argue Jackie Robinson's greatest athlete
of all time
mmm-hmm he's the most important athlete
because if I look at baseball with it
was his fourth day you talking about
importance there's a difference no no
but also a different conversation I'm
talking about importance but I'm also
talking about baseball was his fourth
best sport he played basketball and
football at UCLA he ran track and field
and he played baseball and he went in
the Hall of Fame as a baseball player
okay nobody matches that
I'm not gonna say that I'm not see you
think about you gotta be careful because
you don't want to arguments the level of
today's time on what bo Jackson
displayed was unbelievable I mean Mike
Jordan is like me couldn't hit the curb
all right
who was the pitcher that you just went
over there chilling know what I'm not
gonna play Randy Johnson this pitch huh
oh and it may come grab me off the bench
in like the seventh uh-uh
[Laughter]
mr. plate by three inches and I look
back the guy says you just need three
pitches it's like now you can identify
with John Kruk when Kruk was in the
all-star game beautiful Deion Sanders
Hall of Famer NFL Network analyst and
you can see him tonight and Friday at
9:00 Eastern on NFL Network's Super Bowl
prime and also CD on on NFL Network's
NFL gameday prime following Super Bowl
fit
thank you for stopping Seaton's or
fritzy's
flannel the flannel Seaton's looks like
he's got Shawshank Redemption like shirt
on there doesn't it he got a little
prison blue on there like it works yeah
you're Andy Dufresne is what you are I
like and I love the kitchen I mean you
were really scared when when a-rod just
threw that you were really afraid
would you have caught that yes start
crying actually who had the strongest
arm you know if you're trying to
intercept somebody because Elway had a
pretty good gun for
had a gun okay it was unbridle might
have hurt if he had a gun a lot of guys
you know one more the difference of
those guys back then in us you know it's
like the guys now not only did you have
to deal with my curvy hair deal with
Troy Aikman you had to deal with Jerry
Rice but yet little Steve Young you know
Jim Kelly Andre
these guys had a quarterback that was
also a Hall of Famer there's a different
game enjoy the grill glad you glad you
got it Deion Sanders for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]